Now let's talk about the mechanisms that are there in Exokernel for
implementing these secure bindings. There are three methods. The first method
is Hardware mechanisms. And I gave you this example of a TLB entry. Other
examples of hardware mechanisms include. Getting a physical page frame from
exokernel or a portion of the frame buffer that is
being used by the display. These are all examples of specific hardware resources
that can be requested by the library operating system and can be bound to that
library operating system by exokernel. And exported
to the library operating system as an
encrypted key, and once the library operating
system has the encrypted key for that resource,
it can use that any time it wants. The second mechanism that exokernel
has is software caching on behalf of
each library operating system, specifically the shadow
TLB. Or caching the hardware TLB in a software cache for each library operating
system is to avoid the context switch penalty when exokernel switches from one
library operating system to another. Basically, what
will happen is that at the point
of context switch, exokernel will dump the
hardware TLB into a software TLB native
structure that is associated with that specific
library operating system. And similarly load the
software TLB of the library operating system to which it is switching to into
the hardware TLB. We will talk about
these mechanism in much more detail shortly but
at this point I wanted to mention that this is second mechanism that exists in
exokernel for establishing a secure binding between
a library operating system and the hardware. The
third mechanism that exokernel has for establishing a
secure binding on behalf of an operating system
is downloading code into the kernel. This is simply to avoid border crossing by
inserting specific code. That an operating system
once executed on behalf of it. I
gave you the example of the packet filter earlier. So that's an example of
downloading according to the kernel that needs
to be executed on behalf of a particular
guest operating system. And if you think about it, this idea of downloading code
into the kernel is very similar to the spin idea of extending
the kernel with logical protection domains
that I created and dynamically linked in.
Similarly, in the exokernel world, a library
operating system can, if allowed by exokernel.
Securely download code into the kernel that will get executed under
specific conditions that are laid down by the library operating system.